good morning everyone thanks for coming
out the first talk of the morning so
hopefully you've all gotten enough
coffee and we'll start right in on how
to deliver fast and beautiful images on
the web
real quick introduction about me I'm
Doug siller's I'm originally from the
States I lived in Seattle for 15 years
I'm currently a digital nomad traveling
around Europe with my family I do
freelance developer relations and I got
started on working in the web and native
to help people make their apps and their
websites faster I wrote a book for our
Android developers if you're interested
you can download the PDF here I'll post
the slides so don't worry about if you
don't get a picture of the URL I do a
lot of workshops helping companies and
people build faster websites build
faster apps if you ever want to talk
about any of that stuff I'm the only
Doug siller's on the Internet I'm pretty
easy to find and so when I talk about
speeding up the web people say well why
do we care about that so I'm gonna go
with an analogy that has nothing to do
with the web and I'm gonna talk about
images so one fun thing is I get to
share pictures of cool places I've been
how many of you get a little terrified
thinking about walking across this
walkway that is literally nailed to the
side of an ALP right Yeah right just
about everyone in the room and when we
did this is in Grindle evolved like the
bad guy in Harry Potter when we walked
across this my six-year-old daughter
decided to jump across the thing so we
had this nice rattling thing going on as
we were walking across it but this
relates to performance in that about
three or four years ago Ericsson did a
study and they put sensors on people's
heads and they were measuring stress
responses of different things and they
found that people had a raised stress
response when they were queuing up for a
line and people had astray a raised rest
response when they were thinking about
standing on the edge of the cliff but
interestingly a slow mobile web site is
more stressful than standing on the edge
of a cliff so that feeling you all just
had a minute ago thinking about standing
on the edge of a cliff is what our
customers feel when we build slow
experiences
and if you start thinking about how
people buy things like the mall is
always really brightly lit and there's
always happy music because if you're
happy you buy more stuff but if you're
frustrated guess what yeah there's a lot
of data about this Google found that a
three second delay on a mobile website
causes you to lose 53 percent of your
customers they just bounce a half second
delay on a website they found increased
trust raishin and lowered engagement and
then this study from like almost 20
years ago Amazon and Walmart both found
that a hundred millisecond delay causes
loss in revenue but my favorite stat is
that four percent of mobile users admit
to throwing their phones and this isn't
like that finished contests where people
like to try to throw their phones the
people actually admit to throwing their
phones when there's a slow mobile
experience so what can we do to speed up
experiences on the web and if you look
this is a random 10,000 websites from
earlier this year and I just broke down
like what's the tonnage on these mobile
websites and you can see they you know
we've got a lot of JavaScript we've got
CSS right but just about every single
website is about 50% images so this is
10,000 websites just randomly selected
images make up a huge amount of the
tonnage of data that's sent on our on
our website so what can we do if we can
optimize the images we can make our
webpages load faster or our native apps
I'm going to say native app I may say
web pages but it works for native apps
like anything we can do to deliver
smaller images over the network so let's
talk about four simple image
optimizations anyone know lighthouse a
few hands all right so lighthouse is a
tool from Google and it analyzes
accessibility and performance attributes
of your web page and inside lighthouse
there's four simple image optimizations
there's quality format sizing and lazy
loading and we're gonna go through what
those mean and and how we see it on the
web web page test fans anyone a few
hands all right so if you build web
pages and your interest in performance
webpagetest.org is like oh it's not
there it is all right
sorry webpagetest.org is this great
webpage you can test to see how your
webpage loads there instances all around
the world so you can see how your page
loads in San Francisco in Virginia in
Singapore right you can actually see
what the webpage looks like to your
customers all around the world it's free
it's open source it's really like the
coolest tool out there builds on top of
that is a tool called the HTTP archive
and what this does is every month
it runs webpagetest on five million web
pages mobile and desktop and then puts
all those results in a database it you
can query and you can see what the web
is built of and so what's really cool is
the HTTP archive has lighthouse results
for five million web pages so we can
actually see what's out there on the web
today and we can see how people are
dealing with quality for map sizing and
lazy loading so let's talk about quality
first lighthouse recommends that you
save all your images at 85% quality and
so if you're in Photoshop when you hit
save on a JPEG you can you know you see
the quality bar you can lower the
quality and obviously when you lower the
quality you're lowering you know you
could you can introduce on the screen
you're actually lowering how nice the
picture looks this is a lossy
compression but what Google found is if
you save your image at 85 percent in
general it's gonna look great and no one
will know the difference and the other
cool thing about 85 percent is it
generally makes the size of the image
half of the original size there are a
couple other ways you can do it you can
use image magic which is a free open
source command line tool and here I'm
taking up saying quality 85 just save it
as a quality 85 clouding area is a
cloud-based tool you upload the full
size image and then you add a parameter
in the URL and it saves it as a quality
85 image so what does that look like
this is a Riga Latvia three point six
megabytes and I save it in 85 percent
and it's half the size and it still
looks awesome right so we've made this
image smaller it's going to get
delivered faster and nobody's the wiser
other than the page seems to load faster
so a year ago I looked and so zero is
bad a third of the web was failing this
a year ago they changed the school
whirring and now still 33% are failing
right scoring less than a half 48% are
passing the median webpage here that
it's failing if they save their images
at 85% would be three point seven set
three point seven seconds faster on
mobile and use 130 cal s data right
that's an easy performance win if you
look at these folks down here at the
bottom we're talking like one point six
megabytes less data right huge
performance improvements but eighty-five
percent is just a number that kind of
works for most images what if we went a
little bit better and if I go to 50
percent sometimes you can see some
kerning up in the sky I can't tell if we
can see it here at 20% for sure you can
see this image looks horrible and you
wouldn't want to use this on the web but
where's that rights where's that sweet
spot can we go lower than 85 percent so
we know 85 percent is generally good
we know 20 percent is bad but they're
actually tools that will find the
perfect spot google has a tool called
booter ugly all the compression
engineers at Google live in Switzerland
and they name all their compression
algorithms after pastries and then the
other tool is called structural
similarity and so what I'm gonna use a
structural similarity here there's an
open-source tool that I used right there
I use cloud nari
to quality Auto and what this does is it
lowers the lossy compression until the
human eye can see a difference so if
you're removing pixels and no one can
tell like you're probably okay and when
I do that this was one point eight seven
megabytes at 85 percent so I saved
another 400 kilobytes and the image
still looks awesome right so I saved 400
kilobytes that's great if I run these
images through webpage tests what you
can see is it goes from 20 1.7 seconds
down to nine point five seconds right
we're speeding up the load time of this
image dramatically and there's no impact
to the end user it still looks awesome
other things we can do we can look at
the format of the image so there are a
lot of different image formats out there
if we look this is some older data but
JPEG by far is the king of the images on
the internet but it's also like 25
years old right this is an old image
format it's been around a long time
let's talk about SVG's for a second
vector graphics are really really
awesome and you should use them if you
can so their image is drawn as shapes so
they're vectors right and they're
infinitely scalable so this is the
Twitter logo and if I stretch it it
looks awesome at no matter what stretch
you do if you see any pixels here it's
because PowerPoint doesn't support SVG
so I had to take screenshots on my ass
beat yeah all right you get the idea but
they look great at any size that you
stretch them so I found a website that
was using this SVG is sort of a divider
and something was wrong with it and so I
wanted to see what was going on and it's
XML so I can open up the XML and look to
see what's inside and you can see up at
the top here you can see it's drawing
circles and things like that but it
lined 30 you see it says Adobe
Illustrator and then there's all this
metadata like ooh the the file was 946
kilobytes and the fix here is you click
on line 30 you drag to the bottom you
press Delete and then you hit command s
and when you do that it becomes one
kilobyte this is sort of a testing thing
as well like if you see an SVG on your
web page and is 900 kilobytes
something's wrong and you should fix it
obviously then you can compress it's a
text file so you can compress it to 600
bytes or you can use Google's broadly
right bread you can make it 500 because
it's a newer compression algorithm so it
gets a little smaller now this website
not only had a read sort of target logo
it had an orange one as well now for
those of us who are web developers and
do CSS you can style the red one and
turn it orange with CSS or you could go
their approach and download 1.8
megabytes of circles right this is kind
of an obvious thing if you can get it
down to 500 bytes and two lines of CSS
that's gonna be a lot faster let's talk
about PNG s PNG are an awesome format
they're really really great they have
transparency just like gifts so you can
you know they can be see-through so you
can overlay that
it's really awesome but I found one use
case over and over and over on the web
that isn't an ideal use of of pngs and
so this is from chrome dev tools what's
your image processing pipeline look like
I tweeted those of you who use Mac's may
recognize this file format of screen
underscore shot underscore
year-month-day time right they got the
image perfectly centered on their
computer and then they took a screenshot
and then they pushed that live on to the
internet screenshots are awesome like
this is a screenshot of my tweet and I
put it into my powerpoint like that's
awesome
but when you're putting things on the
web we should look at optimizing these
files and these files are not optimized
to go up on the web I actually went and
found 3,000 images with the term
screenshot in it on the web and I wanted
to see if I could optimize them and so I
turned them into JPEG I went to quality
85 and 86 percent of them got fifty
percent smaller and 35 percent of them
or 10 percent the original size like if
you can take all your images and make
them all ten percent the original size
like that's a huge performance those are
gonna download you know a lot faster
another thing to look at is a web P it's
a newer format it's been around for
about five or six years maybe seven
years now and if I gave this talk about
a year ago support was just starting to
come out on other browsers besides
Chrome so this was a format from the
Google side of things but if you look
now we do have it in every major modern
browser except for Safari and they are
actually working on adding it you eat
there's activity happening in there bugs
right now to add that so web PE files
are generally a lot smaller you save
more data by doing that and so if we
look at this Riga photo again it's
another 400 kilobytes smaller by just by
switching the format to WebP II
obviously not all browsers support that
some of us have to you know Safari
obviously is a very important browser
how many people here so still support IE
browsers right yeah obviously but that's
you know about half the people here
so for things like that you can use the
picture tag where the web P is first and
if the browser doesn't know what to do
with the web P it falls back to the jpg
now that web P is gonna save us another
two and a half seconds and download so
we're still speeding up this image is
getting faster it's downloading faster
let's just jump to here so this is this
year only 18% of the web is passing this
lighthouse score and 60 you know 62% is
failing of those sites that are failing
we're talking six and a half seconds
faster 140k less data the folks down
here at the bottom the median website
here would save 2.4 megabytes and be 15
seconds faster now if you think about
that the median website is at 13% that
means that 13% of the web it would save
even more than that which is astounding
right like 13% of the web could save
more than 2 point 5 megabytes just by
changing the format image sizing this is
sort of responsive images this is what
everyone kind of gets like you serve
different images to browsers that are
used on the desktop than you do to
people on their smartphones and so as an
example here's a picture of a cathedral
in Serbia the original image was 13
megapixels is 1.6 megabytes
I did all the stuff we just talked about
and it went down to 800 K but it's still
13 megabytes or 13 megapixels excuse me
so if I download that onto small little
phone you know you have 13 million
pixels only 500,000 show up on the
screen so you end up throwing away 12.5
million pixels and so this is
essentially a double taxation on your
mobile users they have to download the
whole thing then the CPU has to fire up
and throw away 98% of the stuff that it
downloaded the closest analogy I can
come to that is when you buy something
from Amazon and you have to go through
like 6 meters of brown paper to find out
that your kids ordered a pencil
right we're doing this to our customers
on the web today now to make matters
worse to do that image decoding to throw
away those millions and millions of
pixels it takes time and so this is an
example I did it was 16 million pixels
down to 1 million pixels and on the
desktop
it took 78 milliseconds for that image
decode to happen on a Motorola g4 which
is sort of a mid-range Android device it
was a high range device a few years ago
sort of mid range now we're talking 200
milliseconds for that to happen the
Alcatel 1x is an android go phone it was
sold last year I think you can still buy
it this year as well extremely popular
because they're like 40 euros right
these are phones that people can buy and
if you give them your kid and they drop
it down a drain or something it's not a
huge issue but it takes eight hundred
and twenty milliseconds to decode that
image so it has to download the whole
thing and then it takes an almost a
whole nother second to get it onto the
screen and then when the CPU is running
of course now your phone is getting warm
right because the battery's draining
faster right this is something where
people start to notice that the
performance of the webpage is slower
there are a lot of Android devices on
the market today this slide is actually
about a year and a half old now these
are all of the Android devices that hit
Akamai in one day the size of the box is
how many of each one's things are all
Samsung's the colour is how fast the
processor is we've got a lot of really
slow Android devices out there so we
need to make sure that we're serving the
right size image to those devices so how
do you do that responsive images to save
the day this is something that probably
a lot of you are familiar with in this
case I generated a set of images that
were 25 kilobytes apart in size in the
picture tag I set up a bunch of ice tell
what width and now I'm only throwing
away a hundred thousand pixels a lot
better it's gonna download a lot faster
it's gonna look great and so the tool I
used was a responsive break point I just
said give me a bunch of images between
200 and 1400 make them 25 kilobytes
apart and
give me a zip file you can also there's
a github repo so you can actually
incorporate this into your image
processing pipeline there are a lot of
ways to do this you can look at your
analytics and see which size devices you
have and maybe you only need four or
five sizes maybe twenty-five is a lot it
is a lot but in this case now I've got
the Ultima size image for my mobile
device and what we can see here is when
I run up through webpagetest the load
time drops from seven seconds down to
two seconds and now it's only a hundred
and twenty-one kilobytes this is
reasonable we now have a reasonable size
image it's gonna download quickly and
still look awesome to our customers
responsive images a year ago 57% of the
web past this year were at 58% so really
no change and again 20 a quarter of the
web is failing we're looking at about a
second and a half faster if we could
make our images responsive to mobile
devices again for these people down here
you know the 8% that are completely
failing we're looking at two and a half
seconds faster or 2.4 megabytes
14 seconds faster excuse me so lots of
ways we can take individual images and
optimize them and make them look awesome
lazy loading is another process we can
take this is now something that we put
over our whole webpage and so the idea
here is if you have a web page that
looks like this you only load the images
that are in the initial viewport and
then you lazy load the other one says
people scroll now at load time instead
of 6 images we only have two the web
page is gonna load faster lazy loading
has really taken off last year only 22%
of the web was passing and this year
it's 56% of the web like a lot of people
have been implemented lazy loading the
folks that have not could save 300k 3.1
seconds on their mobile site and again
the people down here you know at the 10%
level scoring a zero and you know we're
talking 12 seconds faster so what do you
do when you lazy load the images a lot
of websites do preview images so in this
case this is a Google image search on my
phone and it Google gives us single
color SVG's that
didn't note that an image is coming and
you can actually see they color code it
based on the most important color in the
image so here I am searching for cats in
costume and you can see the crocodile
one gets a green the cat dressed up as a
bunny rabbit gets a pink right so the
SVG's kind of match up to what's showing
up on the screen if you want to go a
little fancier there's some cool
libraries that will actually sort of
give you a textured look to the SVG this
is again just just nine hundred bytes it
can be your background image then when
the full size image comes in it just
replaces it and so people have kind of
become used to this pattern right medium
does it Facebook does it it's out there
and people understand what's going on
and they know what to do with this so I
built a really slow web page this is the
desktop view in each one of these lines
is showing you know a viewport and so
when I loaded this in chrome a few
months ago this is what happened
you got the text initially and then you
can see slowly the images are coming in
place but what's interesting if you look
at number four the images at the top of
the screen where as a user you're
sitting and waiting for the images to
come in you can see there's a gap you
know you're waiting for something to
come in yet there's a picture of a cow
about two-thirds of the way down the
screen that is fully loaded and ready to
go but nobody cares right because we
don't care about the cow we want the
stuff up at the top to load so what's
happened now is chrome his added lazy
loading by default and you can add an
attribute and you can add lazy loading
into an in Chrome will lazy load your
images automatically so what happens
here is the entire page gets laid out
you can see by frame number three the
entire page is laid out
I've got preview images in place but now
that chrome knows the order of the
images they load from top to bottom
which is the way we scan web pages it
makes a lot more sense all of the images
by number four have loaded at the top of
the page and the cow doesn't actually
appear until number six this is the way
it should be this makes a lot of sense
so lazy loading is gone it's in chromium
browsers now which is really exciting
there are a lot of JavaScript tools that
you can add into your web page to make
it work
on all the other browsers as well now
these are the ones that are in
lighthouse but I have a few other image
optimization techniques that we can
improve upon so when I lived in Seattle
I had goats and this is Nora and I took
a video of Nora and the video on my
phone was 1.4 megabytes and I'm like
this just needs to be a gif all right so
I turned it into a gif and that's
awesome it's Nora eating a leaf and the
problem is when you turn something into
an animated gif it gets a lot larger
you know 270 percent larger so actually
if you go back in history and you go
back to 1990 and you read the
specification for the gif format it says
the gif format is not intended as a
platform for animation even though it
can be done in a limited way so like all
the animated gifs we use like the people
who built the format's like you should
be doing that right it's in the spec and
the reason that is the case is animated
gifs are not optimized through the
through time and so if you have 15
frames per second it's literally 15
gifts that it flips through like a
flipbook every every second so it's just
not optimized for that so if I actually
take the video that I had and I make it
256 colors because gifts are only a min
as 1990 we only had 256 colors I tell my
kids that and they don't believe me
I take out the sound because goats
eating not a pleasant sound and animated
gifs are silent anyway it's only 250 K
right it's smaller this is exactly the
way it should be and you serve it as a
video now you might all be saying like
but gives her everywhere like Twitter
uses gifts right if for those in the
back it actually says gif down here but
what's really interesting is a Twitter's
lying open that up in dev tools and you
can see as an mp4 right there serving
these as videos because there's so much
smaller they get delivered a lot faster
it makes Twitter it makes Facebook it
makes Lac faster so
the gifts that you see on the web it's
sort of gift the technique over gift the
format right we all love the animated
format of looping videos but don't ever
use a gif to serve a gif so the way you
do it is you just use the video tag you
loop it you set it to auto play now
gifts are silent but you still have to
add muted and that's because mobile
browsers won't auto play a video unless
it's muted and then you just put in in
the the mp4 and it'll play and it'll
loop and it'll look awesome if you have
a lot of users on Safari you can
actually put videos in the image tag in
the picture tag which is kind of cool so
in this case the browser will loop the
mp4 or it will do an animated web P and
for those that don't support any of
those and we'll fall back to the
animated gif so that's one way you can
do that of course the animated gif takes
22 seconds to download on a mobile
connection the animated web P takes 18
seconds to download and the movie only
takes four and a half seconds so if
you're really looking at performance the
mp4 is the way to go here it's gonna be
so much faster to download that content
other things we can look at is we can
see what our customers saying what are
our customers telling us in terms of
what kind of content they want has
anyone used data saver mode on their
Android it's now called Lite mode
they changed the name this would
basically it adds a header that says
save data on and so that header is sent
to every single Webb's every single
server that this person hits with their
browser and so this if the server says
hey this guy wants less information you
can serve them less data this is data
from about a year ago Tim found that
five percent of his users have this
header turned on and so five percent of
your customers are saying hey I want
smaller images I want less video maybe
we should listen to them and we can
serve them maybe one size smaller of the
images right just to save a little extra
data maybe remove a few of the images
tools like cloud inari have this built
in so if you have it set to like the
automatic
equality if they see the save data
header they'll actually go a little bit
more aggressive and in this case it
saves about forty five kilobytes right
we're making the image smaller to save
the data for the end user we can also
look at the network and I hear a lot of
people telling you like well 5g will
save the day but they're still gonna be
a lot of people on 4G and 3G for a
really really long time
and if you're on a slow network
connection and I was just at an air B&B
where the whole neighborhood didn't have
fire yet fiber was coming in in a month
and we were all on 3G routers right and
it got really really slow and you know
if you're on a slow connection if your
customers are on a slow connection maybe
you should serve different data when I
lived in Cork for a while I was on a
really really slow connection and I
never got any videos in my Facebook feed
why was that because Facebook knew that
I was gonna get frustrated with Facebook
when I went into the city all the videos
reappeared on Twitter the gifts didn't
animate when I went into the city and I
got fast connection the gifts animated
they change what content is being served
based on the network speed so there are
all these API those are these API is the
network info API and if your customers
are on a slow connection serve them
different content to make sure that they
still get that great experience but it
doesn't take forever to load there's one
more thing I'd like to bring up as
base64 encoding and the idea behind
base64 encoding is you can base64 encode
the images and just throw it straight
into the HTML or the CSS this is an
anti-pattern now and we shouldn't do it
anymore maybe for SVG's that are really
small like under a kilobyte that's fine
but for large images we shouldn't do
that I mean it does mean fewer requests
which was like an HTTP one thing when we
were worried about fewer requests but
the images are now blocking the
rendering of your page
the images are bigger base64 encoding is
like anti compression it's harder to
cache the files right you not to cache
the images as well and they're difficult
to reference more than once so as an
example here's the University of
Nebraska they have this shared CSS
template it's 91
kilobytes 48 kilobytes of this is an SVG
file its base64 encoded but it never
appears on any single page at the
University of Nebraska this is the SVG
right it's got the latin logo and all
that sort of stuff
now it's like why does this not appear
on any single page and it turns out in
their style guide it actually says you
should use the Nebraska n as the main
identifier and never use the university
seal yet every single webpage deliver is
the university seal to every single one
of the people whoever visits their web
pages write every single webpage is
using an extra 48 50 kilobytes to
deliver this content that no one ever
sees just by stripping that out we'd
speed up the delivery of these web pages
when I mentioned they're hard to
reference it just looks like
gobbledygook and so this is a web page
where they have the stars for like
rating different objects and like well
did we add it to the web page I'm not
sure so they just pasted it in again 16
times the same star this is this is a
star image and if you're wondering the
space in between is an empty star that
was there 16 times 2 so this CSS is just
downloading kilobytes and kilobytes of
images over and over and over again that
are all used once so there are a lot of
ways we can reduce the amount of tonnage
that's delivered from our images and so
the way we can do that is we can
optimize the image quality we can change
the format to the optimal format for the
mobile device or the device or the
browser we can resize it for the screen
size we can lazy load the images that
aren't on the screen we should turn our
animated gifts into movies don't base64
encode images and then monitor the
headers of your customers like if
they're asking for less data or they're
on a slow connection maybe serve them
different content I used a bunch of
different tools to build this talk web
page test in the HTTP archive to get the
data on how these web pages are being
built and then image magic structural
similarity of here's some links for all
of those things lazy loading responsive
breakpoints and then to generate a lot
of the images that I used I stored them
all on kalau Denari which is a
cloud-based image hosting platform which
is really cool and
and easy to help do all of these things
as well so in conclusion your images can
be fast and beautiful and with that
thank you so much I'd be happy to take
any questions yeah
image resizer right to resize it so I
yeah so there are a lot of tools that
will resize images for you on the fly
and there are actually a lot of really
cool tools now that are using AI and
machine learning to figure out how to do
the optimal crop because if you have an
image where like I'm on the side and you
crop it in the center you might just
have a picture of an empty stage because
you cropped it and cut off the person
you wanted to have in the image so there
are a lot of tools now that will
actually identify things of interest in
the image to do the cropping so there
are actually a lot of tools out there
that will do that for you now know it's
still really really fast so for example
cloud Neri can do that for you on the
fly and you don't even notice it like it
adds just maybe a couple milliseconds
but it's not noticeable to the end-user
yeah it needs to be zoomable that's a
good point so you know some ways that
that happens if one way you can do that
is obviously I have a thumbnail than the
big image right and then maybe lazy load
the big image afterwards so you get all
the thumbnails and they're really really
fast and that you can lazy load the big
images later because I guess in in
general people see the small thumbnails
and then maybe only see a few of the
large images you may even just depending
on how often people do it you may
actually wait until they hover over the
smaller image to download that there may
be a slight delay there obviously but
there is a cost to delivering you know
if you have seven giant images and
you're downloading it to every single
user if there is a cost to you know
delivering all of that yeah
that's a good question so how much does
dpi matter I read a study that the
person the human being with the greatest
eyesight ever measured can only would
only be able to see the difference
between could not see the difference
between two and three dpi so if you if
you want to use there's no need to go
beyond the 2x when you're doing the DPI
like the 3x you can do it like certainly
but the the images are gonna be a lot
larger and there really isn't that much
more of a perceivable increase for like
99% of the population does that help
yeah
there are a lot of fun tricks that you
can do to make to play with the images
for sure yeah in the back
so the question is if you can only store
the big image or I'm assuming the big
image and you want to resize it
on-the-fly the resizing is really fast
too nowadays if you wanted to do that on
the fly I mean obviously it may be a
little slower than having three images
there and getting it straight from from
storage but it is really fast to resize
them on the fly and to me the advantage
is if you have a 300 kilobyte image and
you can make it 50k on mobile that's
gonna be a huge performance impact to
your end-user just because it's gonna
download six times faster and they won't
see a difference well they will see a
difference in that the page loads faster
but the image will still look great well
cool thanks I'm gonna be around the rest
of the day so if you have any of the
questions just feel free to come up to
me and we can talk about images I'd love
to chat great thanks so much
[Applause]